that why would you get in a relationship
if you don't agree in the first place
I'm seeing that you guys are saying
there's a lot of oh if you don't do this
you're gonna fight go back and forth
like a relationship is a like
pre-contract before you go into it you
sit and say are you good with this the
other person says no I'm not and then
you kind of go back and forth before you
then get in a relationship nowadays A
lot of people want to jump into a
relationship and then you get upset when
things aren't working for you right and
then you start looking elsewhere that's
when cheating starts that's when you
start doing stupid things right and now
the society we're just constantly
fighting for stupid things if I don't
like being with you because you're not
meeting my terms then I'll walk away we
have we this time modern women I hate
that right it used to be something and
like my grandparents or my grandma in
that sense I would call myself a modern
woman but the one woman that my
grandmother wanted me to be back then
they didn't my grandma got married to my
grandfather he was this growing Big Oil
guy right
and she didn't work for a while because
she had everything she wanted she had
all her kids in different countries all
that kind of stuff but she brought up
her daughters my mother in a way that
she had all the education the best
education she could have
um to be a strong woman with will but
still respect her husband all the men in
her family and that is a modern woman
that's what my grandmother wanted her
and her children to be right nowadays
women we come up thinking we have
something we have money we have our own
houses and cars whatever that is so we
want men to be either giving us way more
than we have right or giving having
unexpected realities and we now tag that
as a mother Modern Woman
I'm a modern woman I have I guess
everything I think I want right and now
my mister has seen that I see him on a
certain level
he I understand babe do you bring this
to the table I want you to bring this I
want you to bring that I want you to
bring this he said he could bring that I
accepted the ring
I have all these things what was your
what was your um dating requirements
when you initially was out there when
you were still single before you met
your guy what was the things you was
looking for I was looking for festival
I'm I wouldn't say material things right
because
if I can offer that to you then
that's okay I was looking at
do you understand me do we have the same
values if something was to happen in the
future will you be able to back me and
not not only will you be able to back me
will I be able to stand there and the
stomach you say for it for example he
lost his job
some women find that extremely
unattractive with you know if a man
doesn't have a job like leave me alone
right I had to understand and look at
him and say if that God forbid that
happened to you will I still be there
and the answer was yes and if that
happened to me will you still be there
if you lost all the things that I'm
seeing you have right now will I still
be there the answer was yes and then
that's why I started my thing my what
what about that man made you feel that
like even if he lost everything you'd
still be there what was it that drawn
that draws you to him so
so strongly how he's treated me without
you know
without all the fancy stuff around you
you know sometimes you can sit with
someone in the room without speaking and
you just feel comfortable you just feel
good you don't have to do anything extra
like oh yeah let's go and eat or let's
go on this holiday it's just how
comfortable I feel how he treats me
without all the extra fancy stuff
right that's why I agreed to do that
what do you think that um because you
were saying you hate the term Modern
Woman Etc do you think that that is a
common ideology of modern women today or
do you think that you may be a little
bit niche
I would say I would say Niche is going a
bit too far I would say the different
levels of modern women right the women
you guys are talking about you have to
make six figures if you really look deep
they don't even make one figure right
those people are the people that depend
solely on feeding off of men or women I
don't know whatever sexuality you are
but those people that have these
extremely I wouldn't say unrealistic
because there are people that make six
figures right it's not an unrealistic
figure like top 20 10 of them
because most of the women talking about
this stuff are mid yeah that's what I'm
saying it's levels to it I can't really
get you can't afford it not you but I'm
saying a lot but they've been talking
about can't afford it that's what I'm
saying because it's a trending it's like
to say like boom and I really and
another thing I'd like to say is that I
think that a lot of women go out of
their way to disqualify a lot of guys in
the day in Market yeah and and take
pleasure in that right I'm saying like
you eat like for instance you hear a lot
of women say oh I need a guy that's got
a big Willie if he ain't got a big
wheelie don't talk to me but it's
there's levels it's like it's so many
different little things that that are
out there to kind of tear down men and
make men feel inadequate and stuff like
that now but if if a man comes out and
says well I don't like to date women
that are on the large side shaming
yeah I'm saying like there's a big big
hypocrisy going on in our in our society
and that's why I say that like I feel
like a lot of modern women I don't know
you hate that but a lot of modern women
have unrealistic expectations and then
when those
a lot of times a lot of times men are
very easy to please as well but if a man
comes out and says you know I want a
woman that is in shape oh shaming
everybody like is ready to cancel the
guy yeah do you get what I'm saying what
do you think I think you when you're
looking at a certain type of woman what
type of woman is that so the women that
you you just said a woman could say I
you know I like a man with a certain
type of penis or what what decent
thinking woman would say that in public
right we'll make this known right that's
what I'm saying so you are looking at a
certain type you're looking at the young
girls like I remember when I was growing
up some young girls young girls no but
okay so okay because even in fact it
will be more older women because they
thrown their books around even more so
you've got higher mileage that's
understandable right
if they've got higher mileage they've
experienced more D so then they're gonna
have more of a requirement that I need a
d that's gonna satisfy me
but if you end up and you you end up on
your own with cats boxes of wine ice
cream don't blame no one in it that's on
you you lived here
there's probably things in her and her
personality that she needs to work on
trauma who knows there's a whole
concoction of things that make people
undesirable in the dating world not just
expectations but nonetheless you still
have to deal with the consequences of
your actions there you go what you're
talking about sorry there's high
standards and then there's unrealistic
standards everybody should have high
standards for themselves there's High
School everybody within reason though
yeah high standards that's reasonable
yeah unrealistic outlandish
just standards it's just that's what you
want to have for yourself for me if I'm
going for something I would expect to go
for the best of that right but I'm not
gonna are you the best for myself no but
that doesn't count
listen let me tell you let me explain
what I'm saying let me explain what I'm
saying I would not go into a
relationship thinking I'm not the best
I'm gonna settle because this is what's
the best out there right because I'm
trying to just be like this I wouldn't
do that I would say what's best for me
and I would also consider hoping that
that person is reasonable to consider
what's best for them as well and we may
not be perfect in the eyes of the world
but to us in this relationship it works
for us
out of men and women who do you think is
more inclined to uh be more focused on
self-development in terms of being more
attractive to the opposite sex which
which gender do you think is leans more
to let me do everything I can so that
I'm I'm more attractive to the opposite
sex which it's a no-brainer it's the
women I would say women absolutely
no I would say it's a woman absolutely
not
because for the fact that we have fat
shaming and that only pertains to women
that's a clear indicator literally for
the fact that a woman can be broke
living at home but if a man's broken
living at home you're broke your waste
man bro men on a track
men don't care about your money yes one
voice right like at the end of the day
yeah most of these negative connotations
are so uh specifically
exclusively yeah thank you my bro
exclusively targeted at men women don't
get critiqued like that and usually when
women critique when women do get
critiqued is by other women because at
the end of the day men are easy to
please most men they don't care if a
woman's got money they don't even care
if the woman's in shape do you know what
I mean bro I see a lot of tyrones out
there and their baby mama looks like
crap looks like a duck yeah
bro like come on bro 80 of 80 80 of
women are going for the top 10 20 of
guys like come on bro men are easy more
time yeah a guy won't even mind dealing
with a girl that's average at best if
she don't give no give him no headache
do you think women can women will not be
happy with that and even if she does
like settle with that wall I ain't got
no options I'm aged out I've hit the
wall but she's still gonna be looking
around for the next option she's still
gonna have a hinge account POF Tinder
you get me she's gonna have a work
husband come on bro like you know this
is true that's why you're nothing
slightly that's what I'm saying I'm
agreeing with most of what you're saying
but I still think that women although we
are I think we have this pseudo
confidence now social media's giving
everyone this pseudo confidence to yeah
I'm fat you you're crying inside but
you're still posting that picture and
pronouncing that you're fat so people
like oh you're not fat you know you're
actually skinny so we went the reason
why I said women is because we're still
trying to get affirmation from both
sexes right men are so less Affair and
they don't care they can relax and women
will still gravitate to them as long as
they have I guess money or whatever the
relevance is right to them but women
it's your looks that will get you
everything that's what Society has kind
of created so we are constantly seeking
affirmation and I guess the the head
note from the men that's why I said I'll
say I will say that um women lie to
women and told them that they're
fabulous even when they're not and
they're made and yeah and women lie to
women as well that's what I'm saying
yeah they lie to women
um and and and yeah men are not really
allowed to critique women really the
only reason I'm allowed to do this video
no videos like this and other podcasts
like this is when you have women that if
it was just a room full of guys you were
quite a hater you're a misogynist yeah
you're this you hate women oh you must
have a little Willy like bro like bruh I
do well in real life still come on as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible